foreign
today we're pretty excited to announce
the availability of three New Foundation
models accessible via API on vertex AI
image generation for creating high
quality images from text inputs code
completion and generation leveraging
your code base and a universal speech
model which brings state-of-the-art
accuracy for speech to text and over 300
languages we're also combining the power
Foundation models with Enterprise search
and conversational AI to enable
developers to help Define how they want
generative AI to surface in their apps
Enterprise search complements the
foundation models to help provide
factual update information
conversational AI helps developers make
interactions within their apps a little
more human-like a little more helpful
this is all orchestrated through our new
tool called generative AI app builder
even developers with limited machine
learning skills can quickly and easily
tap into the power of Google's
Foundation models search experience and
even the conversational AI Technologies
to create these Enterprise grade gen
apps
[Music]